[Música]
la Guerra de Ucrania ha mostrado algunos
cambios evidentes sobre la forma de orar
de que tras algunos ataques en crimea
con pocas consecuencias durante el
último año el 3 de mayo drones
dispararon sobre el complejo del kremlin
algunas semanas después las llamadas
milicias anti Putin atacaron la frontera
de belgoroso antes de ser reprimidas por
Rusia este lunes además Moscú reportó
ataques en la ocupada y Ucrania aparece
están empujando las líneas rojas de
Vladimir Putin hay un último evento a
uno no claro y es el que hemos
conversado toda esta mañana la explosión
de La Represa de Noa jacobca vamos al
análisis con Gabriel Merino él Es doctor
en ciencias sociales el profesor de la
Universidad Nacional de la plata y
coordinador del grupo de trabajo de
clacso China y el mapa del poder mundial
Muchísimas gracias a usted Gabriel por
estar en directo a América
Qué tal Buen día Muchísimas gracias por
invitarme en nuestros titulares decimos
que Rusia y Ucrania se acusan mutuamente
de hacer estallar la presa de Nueva
Jacob que parte en el conflicto se ve
más afectada con la inundación masiva
que se está produciendo en este momento
bueno obviamente en un teatro de guerra
las dos partes se ven afectadas por un
lado como Rusia opera la central nuclear
claramente hay una intención de Ucrania
de marcar o sea hacerle pagar el costo a
Rusia por operar a la central nuclear
por otro lado una inundación a partir de
La Represa puede afectar o podría
afectar operacionalmente a las tropas
rusas de cara una posible contraofensiva
ucraniana pero también se ven afectadas
territorio ucraniano creo que ha
escalado ha escalado la guerra estamos
en las previas a unas posibles contra
ofensivas ucranianas y de ahí también
esta tensión en torno a la central
nuclear Bueno sobre eso le quería
preguntar Usted cree que ya empezó la
contraofensiva porque lo titulan así
algunos medios de comunicación y este
último acontecimiento podría generar
también esa teoría
bueno esa es la idea a ver un montón de
de situaciones que se observan tanto en
saporilla como también ciertos
cuestiones en bakmuto o preparativos
parecían indicar una contra ofensiva yo
creo que Ucrania tiene que lanzar una
contraofensiva porque la vino anunciando
hace mucho tiempo recopiló muchísimo
material bélico reunido fuerzas en torno
a una contraofensiva que además
intentó digamos sumar toda la ayuda
posible de occidente y demás de otros
países del Mundo de Cara a esa
contraofensiva para recuperar
territorios ahora la gran pregunta es si
hay condiciones justamente para hacer
esa contraofensiva y ahí hay un gran
interrogante porque hay paridad de
fuerzas porque Ucrania perdió mucha
fuerza las tropas occidentales perdieron
mucha fuerza en basmud porque
no se ve gran superioridad ni de
recursos humanos pero tampoco de
material bélico por parte por parte de
Ucrania entonces Bueno hay hay un hay un
importante interrogante en torno a esta
contraofensiva que parecería haber sido
lanzada por lo que estamos viendo en el
teatro de operaciones
bien está dando evidentemente el paso de
atacar Más allá de sus dominios Y eso lo
hemos visto en los últimos meses los
premios ataques en crimea fueron
percibidos más tímidamente pero por
ejemplo lanzar drones sobre el crimen
supuso el anuncio de un cambio en la
guerra para usted
Bueno ahí hay un intento de me parece
primero hacer una operación psicológica
mediática a nivel global digamos podemos
atacar Moscú podemos
tocar un punto sensible para la política
rusa Me parece que hay una búsqueda ahí
en ese sentido y mostrarlo eso muy
mundialmente el problema es la escalada
que implica eso y el problema es que
desde la otan Son son más cuidadosos con
el con ese tipo de de acciones Porque
pueden
haber puede ser interpretadas como que
se está en riesgo cuestiones
vitales para Rusia y en base a la
doctrina Rusia rusa habilitaría no la
utilización de armas nucleares tácticas
por otro lado creo que también hay una
idea de bajar la moral de la población
rusa de la frontera sobre todo por los
ataques a belgorot aunque no fueron
Bueno más que las operaciones especiales
pero que bueno poniendo como como en
riesgo a esa población y Y afectando esa
moral también para afectar políticamente
a Moscú después en términos
operacionales creo que hay una búsqueda
de que Rusia intensifique o envíe mayor
cantidad de recursos a la zona de
belgorón a la frontera norte que tiene
ahí Ucrania entre Ucrania y Rusia o
cerca de charcop Y de esa manera saque
recursos ya sea del donbas o o del sur
de saponilla eso yo lo veo más difícil
porque si no hay una ofensiva masiva en
el norte Asia Belgrado por parte de
Ucrania
Rusia no va a destinar mayor cantidad de
fuerzas pero bueno quizás dedicar una
contraofensiva hay una idea operacional
de que si Rusia tiene que destinar Más
Fuerzas hacia el norte hacia la frontera
con sharkov y el goroth podría sacar
desde del sur o desde el donbas eso lo
veo más difícil pero quizás hay una
intención de avanzar por este lado miren
nos quedan apenas unos pocos segundos
pero quería preguntarle dejando de lado
los eventos del día de hoy porque el
kremline no parece haber respondido con
una gran contundencia a los ataques en
sus territorios Es cierto que han
aumentado los bombardeos sobre kiev y
que hubo una respuesta en belgoso Pero
también es cierto que no se ven
objetivos pues muy estratégicos en ellos
Más allá del recuerdo amenazante de que
hay una presencia invasora con los
bombardeos sobre quién por ejemplo
creo que no no hay por ahora el premio Y
no no sigues concentrado en sus en sus
planes en sus maniobras en sus acciones
creo que no quiere justamente entrar en
esa jugada de Ucrania sobre el grod o
sobre los ataques a Moscú creo que el
gremio sí se se centró mucho ha mejorado
la inteligencia rusa Rusia y le ha
permitido eso atacar muchos almacenes
debilitando la cantidad de armamento a
disposición de de las fuerzas ucranianas
creo que eso fue una un tema y un cambio
clave vimos durante estos últimos meses
ataques muy efectivos sobre almacenes
también está aprovechando la
superioridad aérea Rusia y creo que está
esperando esa contraofensiva ucraniana
que después hay que ver también si si es
efectivo esta esta maniobra Rusia está
esperando esa esa contraofensiva
ucraniana porque tiene entiende que
tiene muy bien plantadas las defensas
que no tiene superioridad Ucrania de
número y que a partir de ese desgaste
de la fuerza ucraniana por la
contrafecía por una contraofensiva que
podría no ser muy muy eficaz Bueno A
partir de ahí es producir avances la
propia fuerzas rusas creo que está
especulando con eso el kremlin en este
momento Muchísimas gracias es Gabriel
Merino doctor en ciencias sociales y
profesor de la Universidad Nacional de
la plata a ustedes que tengan un feliz
día
Muchísimas gracias Ángela un feliz día
para usted también a nuestros
televidentes continúen con nosotros ya
volvemos con más titulares
[Música]